what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice identifying some
transformations and the transformations
we're going to look at are things like
rotations where you are spinning
something around a point we're going to
look at translations where you're
shifting all the points of a figure
we're going to look at reflection where
you
flip
a figure over some type of a line and
we'll look at dilations where you're
essentially going to either shrink or
expand
some type of a figure so with that out
of the way let's think about this
question what single transformation was
applied to triangle a to get triangle b
so it looks like triangle a and triangle
b they're the same size and what's
really happened is that every one of
these points has been shifted or another
way i could say they have all been
translated
a little bit to the right and up
and so
right like this they have all been
translated so this right over here is
clearly a
translation
let's do another example
what single transformation was applied
to get what is applied to triangle a to
get to triangle b
so if i look at this these diagrams this
point seems to correspond with that one
this one corresponds with that one so it
doesn't look like straight translation
because they would have been translated
in different ways so it's definitely not
a straight translation
let's think about it looks like there
might be a rotation here so maybe it
looks like that point went over there
that point went over there this point
went over here and so we could be
rotating around some point right about
here and if you rotate around that point
you could get to a situation that looks
like triangle b and i don't know the
exact point that we're rotating around
but this looks pretty clear
like
a
rotation
let's do another example
what single transformation was applied
to quadrilateral a to get to
quadrilateral b
so let's see it looks like this point
corresponds to that point
and so
it's and then this point corresponds to
that point and that point corresponds to
that point so they actually look like
reflections of each other if you were to
imagine some type of a mirror
right over here they're actually mirror
images this got flipped over the line
that got flipped over the line and that
got flipped over the line so it's pretty
clear that this right over here is a
reflection
all right let's do one more of these
what single transformation was applied
to quadrotor la to get to quadrilateral
b
all right
so this looks like
so quadrilateral b is clearly bigger so
this is a non-rigid transformation the
distance between corresponding points
has looks like it has increased now you
might be saying well wouldn't that be it
looks like if you're making something
bigger or smaller that looks like a
dilation
but it looks like this has been moved as
well as it hasn't been translated and
the key here to realize is around what
is your center of dilation so for
example if your center of dilation is
let's say right over here then all of
these things are going to be stretched
that way and so this point might go to
there that point might go over there
this point might go
this point might go over here and then
that point might go over here so this is
definitely a dilation where you are your
center where everything is expanding
from is just outside of our trapezoid a